that figure that Dr Adrian ball
mentioned of up to 500 people dying each
week as a result of delays in their care
is that accurate do you think
well I don't think anyone knows exactly
what that figure would be but there's no
question that when the NHS is under the
kind of pressure
that we're under right now that there
are consequences in terms of harms and
risks for patients
and the fundamental issue here is that
we are still as a Health Service in a
position of fragility
it's important to say we don't always
have winter crisis there was a time uh
when we'd have sustained investment over
several years you know over a decade ago
when when it was not usual to have a
winter crisis in the NHS but then we
have the 10 years of austerity that
meant we went into covert in a fragile
state and that meant covert hit us
harder our Health Service and other
health services it meant that for
example we had a bigger increase in
people uh waiting for
so we went into this winter knowing
we're in a fragile state I don't think
anyone was under any Illusions
um that
that would be difficult if you then get
what we've seen which is a huge growth
in flu
and people who are afraid or vulnerable
in hospital with flu and also it's the
impact that the flu has our own Staffing
then I'm afraid you get to the situation
we're in which is that most parts of the
Health Service and you know we focus on
hospitals but this is true of Mental
Health Services Community Services
Primary Care uh are under almost
unbearable strain and that does mean
that we're not able to provide services
as usual we have to focus all our
energies on the most urgent and uh uh
and intense uh needs and that's why
you're seeing the Declaration of
critical incidences in so many places
are you saying that those years of
austerity have essentially broken the
NHS
I don't think there's much doubt about
that we had half as much growth in
health spending as we you know Health
economists around the world when they
look at a country library with aging
population we'll say that we need growth
of around four percent a year and we had
growth of around two percent a year for
a decade and that meant we went into the
covert crisis
30 40 billion pounds less spending than
uh other con uh comparative countries we
went in with a hundred thousand
vacancies we went in with very low
Capital spending so we don't have the
buildings that have the equipment that
we need one of us productive as we could
be and I think the really difficult
thing is this today what I'd like to say
is this that you know during covid
we absolutely said didn't we that we
wanted to learn the lessons from covid
when we saw the way that the Health
Service responded but also the way in
which the Health Service had to stop
doing almost everything else
and we wanted to learn those lessons but
yet we've gone into this winter in an
even greater sense with an even greater
degree of fragility than we went into
covet and we can see the consequences
so what we have to do you know this
winter is going to be extremely
difficult what we have to do is do
everything we can to try to minimize
harms and risks this winter and one of
the things that is vital is that as
ministers return to their desks we do
need to see a resolution to the
industrial action that threatens four
more days of strike action in January
and then when we have got through the
winter because in the end the NHS will
get through even if we have to get
through in ways which are very very
difficult for us and for patients and
for the public then we've got to have a
conversation about what we need to do to
not go into next winter in the same
position of fragility that we've gone
into this one
I mean how does the Industrial action
get resolved though because you'll know
that while it's about conditions a large
part of it is also about pay and the
argument of course is that if you pay
staff more then you don't have enough
money for other parts of the service
well we need leadership you know I
understand the government's position
um limits on public spending worries
around inflation I absolutely understand
the trade Union's position which is
around the fact that their members have
taken real pay cuts
that we have a crisis in recruitment
retention and motivation Health Service
over 130 000 vacancies so in a sense I
understand why both sides would say well
we're not going to move but this is why
we need leadership we need to look at
what's unfolding on the health service
today we need to recognize that January
is the toughest month for the Health
Service
and and government needs to be willing
to negotiate uh in the right spirit and
trade unions need to be and willing to
enter into those negotiations because to
put four days of industrial action on
top of what you're hearing about today
then we were absolutely increase
increase those risks and harms to
patients there is no question and so we
need people to be Pro prep we need
politicians the trade unions be
pragmatic to be creative to find a way
through this not to Heap extra pressures
on a system that is hardly coping right
now okay so what was that pragmatism
look like there Matthew do you want
politicians to negotiate over pay you
you pointedly didn't mention pay when
you talked about negotiating and do you
want to see trade unions bring down some
of their pay demands
well look this is the way negotiation
works both sides have got a starting
point
um but it does look at the moment as
though the the the the reason we can't
make any progress at all is that the
government will not negotiate about pay
and as long as the government refuses to
negotiate about hey I don't see the
trade unions enter into negotiation now
clearly when the trade unions enter into
negotiation it's a negotiation they move
from their starting point that's how it
works but at the moment there's no
conversation going on people are
adopting fixed positions and as long as
they adopt those fixed positions we
continue to walk into four days of
industrial action now your report has
vividly described the pressures were
under now January is out of this month
the idea that we can then take two days
of nurses strikes two days of ambulance
down strike on top of all of this
without there being major implications
for patients well you know it's it it's
a fantasy there will be more harm there
will be more risk
I mean what's it going to look like then
after those extra four days of
industrial election this month as the
services facing the winter pressures
well it will look different in different
places and we will once again have to
ask the public
to support us so in the last ambulance
dispute we saw a significant reduction
in 999 calls now we're grateful to the
public for doing that but whilst It's
always important that the public use the
Health Service in the right way if you
are worried about your health then use
one one use the NHS website use Primary
Care only ring 999 if you have a
life-threatening emergency the problem
is as we saw during covert that if
people stop using the Health Service
because they think it's not there and
there's reports today in Scotland about
this
uh then all that happens is that those
illnesses worse and and that we build up
more pressures for the future so the
situation we're in now where it's
difficult for all the NHS to cope where
so many parts of it having to declare
critical incidents we're not able to
provide the range of services well
that's a problem here and now for people
who are having operations uh canceled
waiting for ambulances but it's also a
problem for the future because it means
that we as a population become sicker
and that drives future pressures
so look the government has provided
extra money to help get people out of
hospital because as you know one of the
issues with God is over 10 000 patients
in hospital who don't need to be there
but that money was announced late it was
distributed even later and so it's not
been able to make much difference this
year
what we've got to do when we've got
through this winter somehow is we've got
to think about how we invest money and
how we do things differently so that we
don't enter next winter in the same
position of fragility and that's what I
would say to people help us to get
through these difficult times but also
keep pressure on the government to act
in ways which which mean that we we
don't have to feel this way this time
next year
so look new year new week New Start
what's your message to the health
secretary answer the leaders of the
unions to try and get this thing
resolved because no one wants to see
those strikes take place again in a
couple of weeks time
I think I want to say this is an
extraordinary time I I speak to NHS
leaders you know just about every day
and a lot of them if not most of them
say that this is the toughest winter
they've dealt with
we cannot go on like this we can't be
sitting here next year saying well this
is even tougher than last year
so we need with the support of the
public and others to get through this
difficult time and I call on the trade
unions and government to find a way of
getting through this industrial stopping
this industrial action taking place
but then we've got not we mustn't get
used to this you know we mustn't be in a
situation we we somehow accept that the
NHS being in this kind of position of
critical incidence crisis in winter is
inevitable in the country as rich as
ours when the Health Service with the
strengths that we've got you know if we
have the resources we can do remarkable
things as we showed during covert as
we've shown to the vaccination program
you know one of the sad things about the
kinds of pressures we're under now is
that we're not able to make the progress
we did make
before the winter in reducing the number
of people wasting a long time for
operations in accelerating our
diagnostic services so the Health
Service can do the job if it's given the
resources and the sport to do so
but at the moment
the fundamental capacity issues are in
danger of getting worse as I said we
went into covert with 100 000 plus
vacancies when I got 130 000 plus
vacancies
so what we need is a national plan once
we've got through the worst of this
winter and a national plan geared
towards that absolute commitment that we
will enter next winter in a in a more in
a more resilient state